my my biggest regret is back in those
days
you know when when all this stuff
happened was to
to fight it not fight it but to like
i've recorded all my show since 1993.
i don't have to fight anybody on
anything if somebody comes up to me and
says hey you're doing my joke i could
easily go what joke is it when did you
tell it
let me go look and then if you did it
before me i'll stop doing it or whatever
it is
like i've always had that yeah but the
ike stayed quiet
and it just got bigger
and bigger and bigger and now
it's just like that's what it is
who opens for you on the road you take
people they are different people
um jade cataprida sometimes what else do
i bring
candace candace i used to bring i like
bringing girls yeah
yeah because guys sometimes i bring guys
and then they try to like bury me i want
them to bury me
i do i know what you're saying you're
like mencia in that way
no i'm not at all like headline
100 not like russell is currently in the
only way that you're like him
just listen to what i have to say okay
but i'm using my own i
i understand that that's not what i know
that you're writing your own jokes
you're an original comic and you're the
best i'm not saying that i'm just saying
in this one give me a different instance
all right i'll give you a different
[ __ ]
there's got to be you're like joe roger
in that way
yeah is uh i mean this is a this is day
late in a dollar show but
i i really feel bad for uh joe rogan
and carlos joe rogan really
he you know and i know he probably
anybody that says is like on his side or
whatever he probably will [ __ ] you
because he went through a lot of [ __ ]
dealing with carlos but carl was finally
just admitted to everything i [ __ ]
steal why can't we have that clip we've
talked about this two or three times in
the show already yeah
he basically no not basically he says
his attitude was this like yeah [ __ ]
steal
if i'm in the back of the [ __ ] room
you better watch your [ __ ] material
because i'll take it remix it and make
it a hit
just like a rap i'll add mexicans well
that means somebody
is old royalties and somebody
you made a lot of money off of these
these people that you steal from but
he's justifying by saying if rap bars
could take someone's like old song and
make it
i i understand but that's that's
basically what he was saying if a rap
guy could do that i could do the same
thing and make it my own
and the argument against carlos would be
that a joke is contingent upon catching
you off guard
music is not like a joke has an effect
the first time you
you know it's could you please stop
saying joke this is the thing that kills
me
i'm i'm ready is that a good quality
back in the day people stole jokes it
was like two jews walked in the bar yeah
it's meant to be told everybody carlos
is taking [ __ ]
your life's analogies man yeah because
these are stories based on your life and
yeah you're a little twist on them and
then just like i said adding mexicans he
was awesome
he was also in it saying hold on why
don't we just play the clip wait wait
wait wait wait i just want to say
something yeah that he this is not just
the clip he's
he's in the whole thing saying here's
what the [ __ ] you supposed to be as a
comic
if you ain't this is a comic you ain't
[ __ ] if you ain't that is a
and then he says i steal which nullifies
he doesn't have a position no on comedy
in in that means that uh what's those
cover bands don't need to say they're
cover bands yeah they could just say
they're the band
[ __ ] you i'm i'm journey i'm playing i'm
[ __ ] journey [ __ ] i'm mario
speedwagon i'm [ __ ] how about you
just know you have a different name
and you'd play all their songs and just
say yeah and just say what i'm i can't
believe he did this my song
like he admitted it to it it was a bad
move and you know he's a
the carlos is a likeable guy man i i
like carlos i see him you he's not a guy
he's one of those guys you can't hate
so it's like but he really he has
no stance on anything else in comedy he
can't say
here's my philosophy right when you're
a thief right like you're justifying
stealing
on there's nothing on any level but the
the bad part is
rogan was on this and and you know they
they ended up pushing him out
away like he was a nut bag for going
this hard
i wouldn't go that hard because there is
no justice because
he's gonna still win my thing is who i'm
mad at not at the business
i'm mad at any person after he's after
he goes yeah [ __ ] steal you better
watch out and this and that
that go see him yeah that's gonna go see
him right
you know he's always nice whenever i i
mean i don't know he's always nice
whenever i see him
yeah he just got a yeah i mean he just
had i guess he was taking material and
that's what people said he was doing did
you know that he was doing that
was it that evident or were you into it
you know i think i honestly
might i don't know that much about it at
all i'm gonna tell you what what it is
and um that was a lot of it but i think
equally as bad was him bumping people
back in the 90s so
you know back you know when you you know
did you you went up this weekend right
at the store or last week sometime yeah
what time do you get spots what 9 45 10
right
yeah i'm more like 11. 11. so if he
gives you an 11 spot right
when you show up at the club you think
you're gonna get up between 11
11 15 right yeah but back in the late
90s
if you're an 11 o'clock spot it meant
people didn't even show up
wow because they knew that they wouldn't
be able to get up damn
because they knew that mencia or eddie
griffin or some of these guys
and they would do three or four hours on
stage what yeah
they let him go yeah they let him go and
they did that
every night and there was like mitzi
just let him go yeah there was like four
or five of them that's
very bizarre that she would let him do
that i remember one time rogan and i
eddie griffin went up for hours and
rogue and i were in the la
not the lobby but out on the patio we're
just sitting there and
goes i'm just gonna leave
i mean you can't you just um to think
joe rogan
what he is now you know what i mean but
they used to do it to him
wow and um imagine all the people that
mencia bumped he bumped with he come i
mean
everyone that's big now right everyone
that's a regular now
at the store was the people that he
bumped for years
a lot of the resentment and hatred
the fuel their careers has now it fueled
them but it also
made them hate the man oh i see jesus
christ it's been
forever and now he admits it man it's
just not admitting it like that and if
there's no backlash and i'm not trying
to
ride but if there's no backlash from
people
that means it's like i'm performing in
front of like
maybe some people that would that i go
why don't i just steal
why the [ __ ] don't i just steal material
that's proof just like rappers and i
don't condone that [ __ ]
but just like them i go look i'm gonna
paint some young guy
who's been in the business six months
does has a great premise
i've seen it all the time great premise
doesn't have the skills
to make that [ __ ] funny i've been there
there's times when i started where i go
man i got this great bit
you know in my mind but it's just not
going to execute because i'm not good
enough
to skillfully do it and so why don't i
just give this guy 100 bucks who needs
it
that's his first comedy dollar let me
take that bit because i see the magic in
it
and don't give them a dime at least
carlos can say i pay these guys
their royalty fee yeah something that's
what rappers do they go look they don't
just go
man i'll sit in the back of the room and
watch james brown and said this
old fool [ __ ] i'm gonna make me
a song they gotta pay that [ __ ] money
man
and his estate but that's uh they don't
have a choice in that
thank you
[Music]
so this is what happened i get this
email the other day from this guy who's
a radio dj
in tucson now who says that carlos
mancia was talking [ __ ] about me on the
radio
do i want to listen to it i said okay so
he sends me the audio file
and it's carlos basically saying that um
he
uh came to the comedy store and that he
went on after me
and that uh everyone in the comment
store calls him the punisher
like he's completely out of his [ __ ]
mind and that uh the only reason why
everybody says he steals jokes
is because they're jealous which is
insane because
have you ever heard anybody saying that
chris rock steals jokes or dave
chappelle steals
no but they're more jealous of carlos
mencia than chris rock
all right here's the problem with this
guy he lives in such a shallow glass
house carlos mancia claims to be mexican
his name isn't even really carlos mencia
that's a fake name
his real ethnicity is he's half german
and half honduran
and his real name is ned wholeness this
is real
this is all real no invented the name
carlos mencia
to ingratiate him with the latino
community of los angeles
so this [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah his name is
ned
yeah he's got a fake name i mean this
guy's so
[ __ ] stupid his whole reason his
whole reasoning for why people
call him a thief is that they're jealous
they're jealous of him
this fake [ __ ] mexican living this
fake life
stealing people's material alright so
what he says is basically that i got the
audio by the way if you want to go
through it
what him on stage yeah no oh that of the
show yeah oh that's beautiful
you want to do that or what it's sure we
can sure sure we can go on but what's
even better
is what i did is i put the audio on my
website
and i have a i hired a personal
cameraman so my cameraman happened to be
there the day carlos
claims that i was watching him from the
stage and instead what we have is me on
stage and him watching me
pacing around the room watching me that
guy imitates everyone including me
all the time he steals from everyone
whether it's
george lopez or paul mooney or old
richard pryor albums the guy's a [ __ ]
idiot and all he does is rehash all
other people's [ __ ]
or rewrite other people's [ __ ] you know
you do a joke about
going to the [ __ ] zoo whatever it is
and if it kills
he'll do a joke about going to the zoo
and just rewrite your [ __ ]
he's a weak minded [ __ ] simpleton and
he doesn't know that people
know he's a weak minded simpleton
wouldn't it be great to be able to
like hear this [ __ ] and then go like
[ __ ] rogan i'm gonna kick his ass
but rogan's such a [ __ ] animal you
can't you can't kick his ass well i mean
why would you want to kick my ass
because i'm telling the truth
that's crazy but i'm not running around
saying that great comedians are
[ __ ]
i love comedy and there's the whole
point the thing that i wrote on my
website joergan.net the whole thing i
wrote this morning at five o'clock in
the morning with no sleep
is that i'm a huge fan of comedy to this
day still am always will be
you know if i'm at the comedy store and
chris rock shows up dude i'm the first
person who wants to sit down i want to
watch great comedy i love it
i love somebody who's got a unique point
of view i love somebody who comes up
with some new [ __ ] that they
crafted i know this guy sat down at his
computer and wrote this all out and
tried it on stage in 15 different comedy
clubs and then boom there it is like
whoa
like i remember when rock was at the uh
the comedy store he was working out his
oscar [ __ ]
dude like me and like 10 other guys sat
in the back of the room
[ __ ] howling loving it love comedy
hate [ __ ] thieves that's all it is
i hate [ __ ] thieves does it [ __ ]
infuriate you
i know the kind i don't know ned
just call him the phony mexican or
carlos menstilia
that's what we want what he's talking
about like the most brutal thief isn't
the guy who just
takes your whole joke it's almost like
mad libs like they'll just like say
you're saying you go to the zoo and you
got a bit
about a gorilla he makes it an orangutan
cookie he was taking a dump dane cook
did that to me
he would did it on premium blend he did
my joke about [ __ ] tigers he did it
with
rhinos genius
[ __ ] genius you know there's so
much of that [ __ ] going on it's [ __ ]
insane it happens in radio all the time
too of course it does
but the new thing in radio is like ah
everyone steals from everyone so it's
okay
[ __ ] that it is you know i love when you
guys do something you credit people
that's that's the way to do it and that
other douchebag that was
you know doing a [ __ ] on channel 152
that you guys were torturing for sure oh
jim phillips yeah
[ __ ] idiot that was that was fun that
was
one of the last shows i listened to
before i got a new car and i i have to
get x7
joe you ever have somebody come up to
you right you just did you said you
killed
some [ __ ] just killed when somebody
comes up seems like yeah you know
i used to do some [ __ ] like that and you
know they're lying oh yeah
yeah i used to do a bit like that it's a
little different you don't have to worry
about you can still do it you can still
thank you minded
i had a guy actually say you know what i
was thinking of doing some [ __ ] like
that
oh that's funny it's just like you what
after i said it
coincidentally they bring back their old
material that they never did
in the first place because they now set
it up by saying that uh
they used to do that material yeah
that's wonderful and what's really
brutal is comedy clubs don't do anything
about it man
i mean it's just the most frustrating
thing in the world for a comic to know
that
your art what you do what you put out is
supporting this club keeping it together
but these people like [ __ ] cannibals
and they they hire these scumbags these
[ __ ] thieves
these just [ __ ] simpleton [ __ ]
who can't come up with anything these
weak-minded [ __ ]
who just just rehash your [ __ ] and these
comedy cups hire them and they expect
you to all work it out
they expect i've actually heard that
argument hey you guys gotta work that
out with yourself you [ __ ]
no he's a thief you [ __ ] know
no one calls someone a thief is not a
feat there's not one
person i've ever heard called a thief
that's not a thief
have you have you ever heard one person
call the thief that's none of it doesn't
exist
there's thieves and there's regular
comedians but those thieves they [ __ ]
make it through they sneak through the
net somehow or another
because the comics don't do anything
about it because the club owners don't
do anything about it these [ __ ]
they swim upstream
and they make it and they have millions
of dollars and they're driving [ __ ]
fancy cars and everybody goes well
you're just [ __ ] jealous
and you're just sitting there going holy
[ __ ] holy [ __ ]
is this for real is this for real